(Music)
Sophie Hawley-Weld: OK,
you don't have to stand up,
but ...
we can see you really clearly --
(Laughter)
So you have to dance with us.
And we have this, like,
choreographed dance thing
that we're about to do --
Betta Lemme: Really easy.
SHW: And we're going to flick
our wrists like this,
and you're going to do it with us.
And you can also stand up.
(Music)
(Sings) I know I did not raise a wrist
(Both sing) I know I did not capture it
It came, it came,
it went, it went
It conquered quick
I was there and then I quit
Awoo!
I know I did not raise a wrist
I know I did not capture it
It came, it came,
it went, it went
It conquered quick
I was there and then I quit
Awoo!
BL: (Speaks) There you go!
(Music)
SHW: We have another one coming up.
It's a little finger-pointing dance.
(Music)
The people sitting down,
I want to see your fingers pointing.
Yeah!
(Sings) I know I did not raise a wrist
(Both sing) I know I did not capture it
It came, it came,
it went, it went
It conquered quick
I was there and then I quit
Aaaa ...
(Applause)
Awoo!
(Music)
(Clapping to the beat)
Aaaa ...
SHW: (Speaks) Alright, hand flick.
(Both sing) I know
I did not raise a wrist
I know I did not capture it
It came, it came,
it went, it went
It conquered quick
I was there and then I quit
I know I did not raise a wrist
I know I did not capture it
It came, it came,
it went, it went
It conquered quick
I was there and then I quit
(Music)
Tucker Halpern: You guys are way more fun
than I thought you'd be.
(Laughter)
(Music)
Awoo!
(Applause)
SHW: Thank you so much.